[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIVIAN XU: My name is Vivian Xu.
I'm a product manager
in Google Cloud.
And I have Ed Hammond,
Senior Enterprise Architect
from Cardinal Health today
here with me as well.
So from the title
of the session,
you probably can
expect we're going
to talk a lot about an
industry, highly regulated
with a lot of security and
compliance requirements.
So today we're going to
break it into three parts.
The first part, we'll talk
about how Google Cloud supports
an industry with a high security
and compliance requirements.
And then Ed will come and
share his best practices
in Cardinal Health, how
he improves developers'
productivity without
compromising their compliance
and security requirements.
And third part, we'll bring
it back to GCP Marketplace
and share with you how
developers and enterprise
procurement team can
benefit from the Marketplace
with their deployment as
well as procurement support.
OK, so let's get started.
So as we all know, security and
compliance is a collaboration.
It's a shared responsibility
between Cloud and the customer.
Depending on the deployment
model that you choose,
whether it's
infrastructure as a service
or platform as a service
or software as a service,
the responsibility breakout
between Cloud and customer
are different.
And the Google Cloud
does a lot of work
to make sure that
our part is a secure,
meet the compliance requirements
so it can better to support you
while you need to meet your
compliance and security needs.
So more specifically,
we do [INAUDIBLE]
from the three parts.
The first part is protection.
Protection is done when Google
Cloud design is infrastructure.
The security is in the design.
It's built it, part of
the design from the chips
to the compute, networking,
storage to the data center,
we have security built
into all of its designs.
And also control, GCP offers a
wide range of control for you
to meet your policy, regulatory,
and business objectives.
And the last part is compliance.
As mentioned, we work to meet
our compliance requirements
so that we can better support
you and make your compliance
work easier.
So just to give
you an example, we
know that our customer
and the regulator
expect us to work
with the third party
independent auditor to look
at our compliance to make sure
that our policy, our
operation, our infrastructure
are all meeting their security
and privacy compliance
requirements.
So that's reason that you can
see here we have regularly
worked with the
third party auditors
to do all this certification
and compliance.
And that includes
both internationally,
globally-accepted compliance
standards as well as
regional, local standards.
So that makes you,
when you need to meet
those your side of standards
and the compliance requirements
easier when you either go global
or you go to a specific region.
And we continue to
expand this list.
And at the same
time, you'll probably
recognize some of the
partners named here.
They are top-notch
security partners
that we are working with.
They are probably already
in your on-prem data center.
So when you move to GCP
Cloud, those partner solutions
are all GCP Marketplace as well.
So you can have a consistency
between your on-prem data
center and the Cloud.
You can have the same
security posture.
And the cloud technology,
from the feedback
that we collect
from the customer,
really represents a fundamental
shift for health care.
Traditionally, on the
on-prem environment,
you have an inflexible
software deployment, right?
It's really hard to deploy,
to update, to patch.
And as a result of that,
most of the developers,
a lot of developers' cycle
goes into maintaining
that infrastructure
instead of developing
business-focused
applications and solutions.
And as a result
of that, you might
have complex rigid offers.
And also data are siloed.
It's hard to get a holistic view
of your patient information,
of your system,
of your solution.
And also, is it
[INAUDIBLE] space.
So it usually goes
through a long approval
cycle with a large procurement
team within your organization.
With a Cloud, the
promise of Google Cloud--
cost reduction, universal
access, up-to-date,
and the flexibility--
we see some of our
health care customers
moving to a new model, the model
that are built on top of Cloud.
So with that model,
first of all, software
is very easy to deploy.
It's very easy to
maintain, patch, or update.
And as a result of
that, you save the time
from maintaining infrastructure.
You save the time from
patching your software.
The developer can really
focus on your true IP, focus
on business value applications.
And with that, you'll also start
to have data coming together
from a patient-centric view--
how you can view your
data everywhere anytime
you need or your customer needs.
So with that being said,
I want to welcome Ed back
to the stage.
And he will share with you how
he improved the developers'
agility in Cardinal
Health without sacrificing
any security and the
compliance needs.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
ED HAMMOND: Thank you.
Can you hear me?
You got me?
All right, there you go.
We're glad to have you all here.
Hopefully this will
be of value to you.
If you don't know anything
about Cardinal Health,
Cardinal Health is a
large health care company.
And we're concerned about
providing products and services
to hospitals and
solution providers.
And we are multinational.
You can read the slide up here.
So this talk, what we're
trying to focus in on here
is who is going to try
and use this information.
Really, our goal
is to try and help
the centralized IT staff as
well as the distributed staff.
We have people all over the
country, all over the world.
They're supporting
IT capabilities
at various different stages
in their sophistication--
so simple developers,
full DevOps teams,
or researchers-- for
example, true BI researchers,
AI researchers, or architects.
I'm an architect so
I play around more
than do operational things.
And what we really want to try
and do is get the consistency.
When we deploy
things out, we want
to have a consistent framework.
Consistency is always
good in data processing.
We also want to have
efficiency, because we're really
cost-conscious, obviously.
And so we want to
be able to maximize
the utility of the
things that we develop,
use once-- or build once, reuse.
And then zero to ready.
I had this zero to
60, but 60 what?
Zero to 60 in 60 seconds
so that you can actually
deploy an instance very,
very quickly, almost
on the competitive
nature of what
you might do for a container.
And ensure that we have
a secure environment.
OK, so about security.
Security is all about
protecting our customer data.
There are lots of
regulations out there.
They care about us trying
to protect customer data.
And we have to have
multiple layers of defense.
You don't want to have a
single misconfiguration create
disaster.
So you have to put several
different things in place.
Obviously you have to
have logging, monitoring,
compliance, audit, all
those kinds of things.
There are HIPAA
requirements that you
have to maintain certain
audit logs for seven years.
Some other data has to be
maintained for 40 or 50
years, that kind of thing.
So you have to think about all
these kinds of considerations.
And we use several
products in our ecosystem
to try and provide that
multiple layers of defense.
But by the same token, we
want to go to Cloud native
as much as we possibly
can so we can test
new and different products.
We sort of heard about Anthos.
We've also heard this
just this morning
about new artificial
intelligence,
BI kinds of capabilities.
So we want to take advantage
of those very, very quickly.
So we really like the
pay-as-you-go model.
One of my executives--
I have it on the
side-- he talks about
as being a disposable
technology stack.
But pay-as-you-go
means zero commitment.
Traditionally, if you're going
to try and get something,
you had to go in this year-long
or three-year-long kind
of contract cycle.
In this world, I can
use it for three months
and then deploy something
different if I need to.
Now traditional
technologies really
haven't caught up with this.
This is a real challenge
for a lot of the vendors.
Some of the vendors that you
saw on Vivian's earlier slide,
they still sort of
try and move you
toward a one or a
three or a five year
commit on purchasing
some of the licenses.
So we as an industry need to
help vendors move into this
pay-as-you-go model.
And it's going to be a
challenge for us all.
When you start talking about
infrastructure as code,
everybody needs to
become a programmer.
What I mean by that is rather
than having a Windows systems
administrator try and
work with the windows GUI,
everything needs to be in code.
Everything needs to be in Git.
You push it up, the whole
instance is fully configured.
We do that for Linux.
We do it for Windows
and so forth.
So, again, protecting
our customers,
we use standard approaches.
Because we're lifting and
shifting a lot of our workloads
from on-premise data
centers into the Cloud.
And when you do that, you can't
change everything all at once.
So therefore, there are
tools and techniques
have been used traditionally
in some of those security
appliances that we
just can't throw away,
that we have to maintain.
And there is not a
Cloud native equivalent.
So we had to bring those
appliances forward with us.
And they're used largely
for the segmentation.
There is some business
function put in there,
but it's largely for
segmentation and isolation
of workloads.
There is also the challenge
of separation of duties.
You hear a separation of
duties and quite often you
think about two different
groups doing things, right?
This group has to
do firewall rules.
This group has to do this.
This is a test team
and that kind of thing.
Well, when you think
about DevOps and everybody
being a programmer and
click a button and now
I have a full
production environment.
That really challenges
that separation of duties.
So therefore you have
to put into place CI
to CD workflows and checkpoints,
approval checkpoints,
to make sure somebody doesn't
release something incorrectly--
either maliciously
or accidentally.
We also developed
standard patterns.
We vet that.
We think about it.
We design it.
We test it.
We develop standard
patterns and we
want to deploy those
on a consistent basis.
So we use something
called golden images.
You could call it
whatever you want.
It's sort of like a CD that
you can use that has everything
on it that you would need.
That also helps prevent
the common mistakes
that you're going
to naturally have.
We also put that in
the network as well.
To ensure that we don't have an
accidental thing get through--
obviously that would
be a bad thing--
we have reactive
controls as well.
I'll give you a case in point.
In the network, if someone puts
in a network firewall rule,
that's incorrect.
We have Cloud functions that
automatically shut those down
within seconds.
We do the same thing in
some of our images as well.
OK, so the golden images.
Let me talk about that one.
We take the Marketplace images.
And we have a number of
them that we support.
We take those Marketplace
images and we use Packer.
And we add on to that
marketplace image
a number of different
security products
and a number of different
configuration items
that are necessary to run a VM
instance in the environment.
We take those and we have them
as a private image family.
And we share that, authorize
use, give permissions
to service projects,
authorize that use
to the service projects.
So developers can just
pick those off the shelf.
And they have everything
that they need to be secure.
So, again, we apply hardening,
CIS hardening scripts.
We install binaries
and other products
that we need to have on there
that are required for security
compliance purposes.
In Windows, we
CIS-prep the images.
Or in Linux, we redact out
some configuration items.
And then we do
automated pen testing.
We actually deploy some of these
and do pen testing afterwards
to make sure it's all solid.
We try and do this
on a monthly basis.
It's pretty much automated.
But with things changing, you
know, some technologies change,
there's some manual
in there as well.
But generally, it's
fairly well automated
that when a new image
comes out, we update it.
The other advantage about this
is once we put that up there,
the boot image, so that
licensing material that
needs to be there, that's
maintained with these images.
So there's no additional effort
on the developer's standpoint
to deploy something.
Now for special use cases, we
have some security appliances
which are really
special use cases.
They had many network adapters.
They had many,
many considerations
that you have to
take into account.
We took the golden image--
took the image off
the marketplace
that's provided by the vendor.
And we have a batch script,
fairly simple batch script
that runs Deployment Manager.
And the real physics
is in that YAML file.
In the YAML file, we
put in all the material
that we need to
customize that image.
I use the term boiler
plate settings.
But it's all the things
that you need to do.
For example, something silly,
like on every system image,
you have to have the
disclaimer that your actions
can be monitored, right?
That's a legal requirement.
Everybody has that
on their systems.
So that has to be on
every single image.
Where are the DNS servers?
How are you doing NTP.
All of that kind of stuff
is part of this boilerplate.
Every image should get
this kind of material.
So we put that all
in this YAML file.
And so from 0 to
60 in 11 minutes--
and that's with three
reboots because I'm
switching network adapters
and provisioning modules
and resizing disk drives
and that kind of stuff.
Within 11 minutes, you can have
a fully production security
appliance deployed and ready to
go, from 0 to 60 in 11 minutes.
That's pretty powerful.
Give you an example.
Just last week, we had a
brand new engineer come on,
very skilled in networking,
very skilled in working
with this class of appliance.
And she had never
seen Git before.
So I sat with her for an hour
and a half, going over Git,
helping her to
understand Git and Bash
and that kind of thing.
But once we went
through that, she
was able to actually
use the deployment
and build two instances
in 11 minutes.
So it was pretty
straightforward.
Once I got her past all the,
"you're now a programmer,"
she was able to do her job
very, very effectively.
So, therefore, she didn't
have to go and figure out
all this YAML boilerplate,
and everything else.
Traditionally, when you
think about deploying
some of these
hardware appliances,
it's several hours of somebody
going through and configuring
this and configuring that
and so forth and so on.
So infrastructure as code
really pays the value.
So another one that
we were worried about
is once you put one
of these appliances
out there, what happens
if you have a disk drive
failure, right?
That's always a worry.
And in the physical world,
you have two disk drives.
And you have the active standby
pair and those kinds of things.
Well, on the Cloud, you don't
have this active standby pair.
Everything's active active.
OK, so what happens if
you lose a disk drive?
Well, we take snapshots.
We're doing hourly snapshots.
So the disk drive
gets corrupted.
Which hour do you want
me to recreate from?
With the YAML file, deployment
manager, we can destroy,
rebuild inside of five minutes.
So if today right this second
somebody called me and said,
I need to rebuild from seven
hours ago, I could take it,
five minutes, you've
got it back again.
That's pretty powerful.
On each one of our instances,
we have all the logging
and monitoring tools.
This little icon there
is representative of one
of the very common large scale
logging and monitoring tools
that many people use.
But we also use Stackdriver.
We also use Cloud storage
as logging and monitoring.
For example, I mentioned
that in some cases
we have retention periods
of, you know, many years--
7, 40, 50 years of retention.
Doesn't make sense to maintain
a brown spinning disk.
Sorry.
It makes sense put
in Cloud storage
so that you can have that
really long retention.
Now, of course, you're
going to apply life cycles
to all of that so that you're
going to throw away data
that you don't need as
quickly as you need to.
OK, so the buying models.
How many people have ever
tried to-- you know, you
get something and
they say, we'll
give you a 30-day
free trial, you know,
and so forth and so on.
I don't know about you, but
I've never ever, not once,
ever had a 30-day
free trial not get
extended two or three times.
So, typically, what
you need is you
need five hours of dedicated
time over 120 day period,
right?
I don't know about
you, but I get busy.
And I run from meeting
to meeting to meeting.
Well, in this case
what I can actually do
is I can spin up an instance,
work on it for an hour,
shut it down, go to meetings, go
off to a conference for a week,
come back, run it for another
hour, and that kind of thing.
So I have it over
a long duration.
Again, we were talking about
this disposable technology.
So one of the things since we
started adopting the Cloud--
we've been on this journey
for several years now--
is we did not want to
get into a position
where I make a
technology decision today
and I continue with
that technology
just because I bought it.
One of the challenges you run
into is as soon as you buy it,
then you wind up using
more of it, which
means you are locked into it.
And we want to be able
get out of that vendor
lock in kind of case.
So when we start
thinking about some
of these security
appliances, when I start,
I said, great, that's my
current architecture for today.
And if Google comes out with
a competitive advantage,
I'm going to drop that one,
flip over to this other one.
And so I don't want to be stuck
into a particular technology.
Now that actually challenges--
if you think about it--
the traditional purchasing
model, all right?
So, in our case, we're a
publicly-traded company.
And certain layers of management
have certain spend authorities.
I'm sure you probably have
the same kind of thing.
And in the old capex
model, it was, well,
you have to do a capital
purchase request.
It has to go
through procurement.
It has to get 12 signatures
and so forth and so on.
Some of these appliances
can be fairly expensive.
One of them, as I've
shown here, is $85 a day.
Well, after, you
know, I spin out
five or six of these things,
run it for several days,
if my manager doesn't have
the proper spend authority,
now it can be in a problem.
So you constantly have to go
through education of people
to make sure they understand
what you're spending.
And turn off the lights.
I talk about this all
the time to the people.
Didn't your mom and dad
ever tell you to turn off
the lights when
you leave the room?
We need to always turn off the
lights whenever we possibly
can.
We do that across the board.
We have a number
of tools that we
use to try and turn off the
lights automatically based
on time and also
based on utilization.
But the other notion is build
it only when you need it.
Don't build it two
weeks in advance.
Build it the day or the hour
or the minute that you need it.
And then destroy it as
quickly as you possibly can.
That's a really
different mindset.
If you ever worked
with any project team--
for example, I was working with
one for our e-commerce team.
And they were saying, we have
to have all these servers built.
You know, we have to
have 10 servers this way
and so forth and so on.
And I said, well, OK,
when do you need them?
On Friday.
And I said, OK,
what time on Friday?
They said by Friday afternoon.
OK, I'll be build
them at lunchtime.
No, no, no, we need
them by Monday.
Why?
Because that's what we do.
We have to get them on Monday.
That's the project.
You get them on Monday and
we'll use them on Friday.
I said, no, I'm going
to do it at lunchtime.
So, again, that model is
very different from most
enterprises.
So my summary slide,
the advice for others,
I would recommend the
concept of the golden images.
Now, there are exceptions.
For example, I was
just mentioning
there's a lot of chatter this
morning on an email back home.
Somebody wants to use an image
off the straight marketplace.
And I said, great,
you want to use
the image off the marketplace?
Then you get to go through
the five pages of steps
that we go through to
build the golden image.
But I don't want to do that.
Well, then your choice
is to use a golden image.
So we're calling
these not standards,
we call these
accelerators, trying
to make it a
positive experience.
If you use the
accelerator, you go fast.
If you deviate from that
and use something different,
it's going to slow you down.
Have a solid maintenance
pattern of how
you're going to actually
deploy these things,
how are you actually
going to use them,
and communicate that
with your customers.
We use Shared Templates
for common deployments.
In Deployment Manager, we
have a standard template.
And in literally in
about 12 lines of YAML,
the host name and whatever
else you're going--
what network you
want to put it on.
In about 12 lines
of YAML, that's
all you need to
spin up an instance.
And you can get it in
two or three minutes.
Domain joined if it's Windows
and all that kind of stuff.
OK, use the power of
the startup script.
That's how we're
doing some of that.
And we also use Cloud
storage very heavily.
For example, another
one is somebody
wanted to create their
own Jupyter notebook.
OK, so they wanted to create
a set of images for that.
So what we did was we
use a golden image.
And to do the Jupyter notebook,
it was a 61-gigabyte file
that they needed to install.
So we put that in Cloud storage.
When the instant boots
up, it downloads it
from Cloud storage,
configures it, there you go.
And the last note
that I might say
is if your folks
are not programmers,
they need to become so.
It's going to be a
challenge to not have
programmers in your enterprise.
So that means a skills
uplift at times.
It means training.
It means patience
with people learning
how to use tools like Git and
manage infrastructure as code.
So we'll have some time to
take questions later on.
And I'm going to turn
it back over to Vivian.
Sorry.
VIVIAN XU: Thank you so much.
It's always exciting to see
how GCP empowers enterprise
and learn from the best
practice from those enterprise.
So Ed mentioned, you know,
they start their deployment
from GCP marketplace.
So I want to just deep
dive a little bit more
to the GCP marketplace and
also share other capabilities
on the GCP marketplace with you.
So we build the GCP
marketplace really
for enterprise development.
We enable the developers'
productivity, right?
We have those vetted, tested
solutions on GCP marketplace.
They can download and
use it right away.
We have to simplify
the management.
So we will talk about
the Deployment Manager.
Ed also mentioned that's
something they use
as well as some new capability
in the Kubernetes application.
And at the end, I think
this is for everyone,
enable procurement.
Billing, invoicing,
procurement, budget approval
is never really a fun process.
So GCP Marketplace tried
to simplify that for you.
OK, so let's look at the
developer experience first.
Ed mentioned there is a very
rich catalog of solutions
on GCP marketplace.
There's a lot of categories.
And it covers a wide
range of the vertical.
And in terms of
form factor, we have
VM solutions, Kubernetes
applications, data size, API,
software as a service, right?
So any form factor
you can think of,
you would need it to
build your application.
You can find that
in marketplace.
And second, the
Deployment Manager.
And Ed already showed
the Deployment Manager
in his example that it can
simplify your deployment
of what is required.
And it really allows you to
do very powerful customization
as well.
For example, building
the golden image,
and embed a golden image
into the deploy manager
in Cardinal Health's example.
And the last one is the
Kubernetes application.
Very happy to announce it's
going GA, the Kubernetes
application on GCP marketplace.
We worked very hard
with a lot of partners
to make this another
type of solution on GCP.
And then we also have the
simplified management update
for you in alpha.
So the reason that
we worked so hard
you get Kubernetes application
on to GCP marketplace
because we heard from
you that a you want
a solution that you just
need to build a once
and it can run anywhere.
So we did that.
With Kubernetes application,
you can run that application
in your on-prem environment,
on top of Anthos,
or on any Kubernetes cluster.
And then you have
the flexibility
to move that solution between
those environments as well.
And the Kubernetes
application, also it
has the pre-build template,
deployment template
into the application.
So that simplifies your
deployment experience.
And the last, again, this
will be another line item
your GCP bill together
with the GCP resource
use together with the other
partner solutions you use.
So you'll have a consolidated
billing in one invoice
from GCP.
And talking about
managed updates, right?
We understand that
deployment is not enough.
What you really
need is management.
It's the lifecycle management.
So we are introducing
managed updates
for Kubernetes application.
OK, so we are introducing
managed updates
for Kubernetes application.
First of all, you can
leverage that capability
through our GCP UI as you
can see on a screenshot.
It allows you to
patch any security
vulnerability or any updates
to application much quickly.
And second, this managed
update has the auto rollback
capability.
So you define the
rollback condition,
any condition you need.
And GCP will do the house
check for your application.
Once the condition is met,
the auto rollback trigger
will happen, right?
So you don't have to monitor
your system very closely as
long as you've defined
your condition very well.
Because the rollback will
happen automatically once
the GCP detects that.
And the last-- the
current manager update
is supported on the [INAUDIBLE],,
as well as the GCP UI front.
So as a developer if you
want to integrate that
into your system using the
[INAUDIBLE] that's available.
OK, so since we talked about
Anthos, just kind of a recap,
Anthos is a Google-built,
Google-managed software stack.
And it allows you to deliver
your applications into a hybrid
and a multi cloud environment.
So it has the automated policy
and the security built in.
So you can do the policy
management and the security
management at a scale.
And it also has
a very consistent
operational management for
consistent control plane
experience you need when you go
across multiple environments.
And, of course, we always build
an ecosystem around a solution
that we deliver.
Anthos has a very strong, very
powerful enterprise ecosystem.
And as you can see,
Kubernetes application
as one of core into Anthos
has already so many partners
offering their solutions
on GCP Marketplace.
And the customers are looking
at those Kubernetes application.
And they can deploy it easily
using the Kubernetes managed
update, can use our tools
to easily spin them up
and down in their environment.
And also, as Anthos promised,
we are doing hybrid cloud.
You not only can
deploy your application
into GCP, GKE, but
also the GKE On-Prem.
And we made that happen
with our partners as well.
For the partners of
this here, not only
you can deploy them
in the GKE in GCP
as well as the GKE On-Prem.
And we are working with the rest
of the Kubernetes application
partners very hard to
make them, their solution
available on prem.
So this way, you really
have the consistency
across different
environment, whether it's
a customer-built application
that you build yourself
or a partner
solution that you are
getting from the marketplace.
OK, so GCP marketplace.
We talk a lot about
Kubernetes app.
But GCP marketplace really,
has a lot more other solutions.
Just to remind, we have VM.
We have SaaS.
We have an API.
We have a data set.
And that covers a wide
range of use case.
So as far as security, database,
networking, storage, machine
learning, AI, big data,
you name it, right?
We have all type of partners
offering these solutions
on the GCP Marketplace.
So we talked about
the developer.
It's easy to use
from the Marketplace
from the developer
point of view.
What about the enterprise?
First of all, we have a
very flexible pricing model.
As Ed mentioned earlier,
they want usage-based.
They want to have disposal
technology, right?
Disposal means I'm
not wasting anything
if I switch my technology stack.
And usage-based
pricing allow you--
or pay-as-you-go
allow you to do that.
There is no pre-commitment.
There is no
pre-contract negotiation
or a very long budget approval.
You can just use and
pay for what you use.
Then the second is we understand
when you move to production,
when you have a more
stable environment,
you probably need a more
consistent billing model.
So this is a where we provide
a monthly subscription.
We provide you
annual subscription,
multi-year subscription.
And annual subscription is
coming in beta very soon.
So this way, you will
get the consistency
you need when you move into
a production environment.
And the second, we know that
you will work with your vendor
pretty closely.
And then most of the time you
might have custom contract,
you have custom pricing.
So this is a where we allow
you to continue to leverage GCP
Marketplace, right?
You don't have to go
to another channel,
go to another
procurement process
because you have a discount
negotiated with your vendor.
So in using the private
pricing, your vendor
can create a code inside the
GCP and deliver that code to you
through GCP.
And all the transaction
or the procurement
will still happen using
the GCP billing system
and eventually the
vendor charge will also
show up on the GCP bill.
So preserve the single bill
benefits you get from GCP.
And the last one is
a private catalog.
Ed mentioned that they
have those golden images
they try to put into a catalog
so that their developer can
easily leverage them.
We are building that
service as well right now
to make that even
that process easier.
So the private
catalog will allow
you to put your golden image
into that with the right access
and control.
And then your developer
can just grab it
from the private catalog.
And the private catalog
right now is in beta.
So just want to show
you some example.
You know, Cardinal
Health is not only
example using GCP marketplace
where you have an increasing
number of large
enterprise customers
are deploying their solution,
looking at their entire product
lifecycle from
development to production,
and looking at those solution
from the marketplace.
Are seeing developers are
stacking their building blocks
from GCP Marketplace--
whether it
is a tooling, whether it's a
firewall, whether it's a load
balancer, or whether
it's a database.
And we are seeing
the IT operation
also deploying solution
from the GCP marketplace.
Because they see the
ease of deployment
and the management
and risk-free.
A few more capabilities just
to mention on the integration
that we do with the
other GCP services.
Cloud Security Command
Center, so this
is a GCP service provides
you are single pane of glass
for the threats that you
might have in the system
then take action immediately.
Not only you can
deploy or provision
Cloud Security Command
Center from GCP Marketplace,
but also we integrate some of
the security partner solution
into the Command Center.
So as a result of that, not
only you see your GCP resource,
how their security posture is,
and then take action on it,
you can also see your
vendor security solution.
So you have a complete picture
about your environment.
And as you have heard
from our keynote,
we will also welcome
those open source partners
to GCP marketplace.
Not only they will have the
same ease of use from the GCP
marketplace concerning
the billing,
but also will offer additional
first party experience
to make you, when you
use those open source,
experiences really great.
And we also want to welcome the
newest Kubernetes app solution
from Palo Alto.
This is the security adaptor
Palo Alto offers on the service
mesh.
And, again, this is a
solution on GCP marketplace.
But you can deploy either
on GCP or the GKE on-prem.
So this is already running
fully integrated with our Anthos
option.
And we want to welcome more
and new and updated listing.
This list just
growing by the day.
Everyday we have a new partner
either adding their solutions,
additional solutions
to the marketplace,
or a new partner with a new
solution coming on board.
Great, so I've been talking
about our enterprise
developers.
But just in case you
actually have a solution,
please come sell
on GCP Marketplace.
As you can see
with the GCP, first
of all, global visibility,
increase global sales,
e-solution delivery.
We do have a high bar to make
sure that your solution is
secure and easy to deploy.
And you have a lot of GTM
opportunities with Google.
So just to recap, Google Cloud
provides products, solution,
templates, best
practice to support you
with the high requirements
and the compliance.
Ed from Cardinal Health
shared their best practice
how to improve the
developer's experience
to improve the developer agility
without sacrificing anything
on security and compliance.
And at last, GCP
Marketplace is your catalog
for any application
solutions you need
to build your own business.
[MUSIC PLAYING]